okay so this is this is the these are
the questions the first
one
is runs like this how to know if you're
ready okay this is for young people I
think if you're ready to enter into a
relationship and biblically speaking
what are the qualities that should we
look for a man and a
woman uh let's pray first
Our Father in heaven we thank you for
the knowledge you've given to us in your
word we thank you de God for the spirit
that makes the word clear to
us as we try to answer these questions
speak directly through me I pray and
through my brother that your people may
gain an understanding of what you would
have them to do and how you would have
them to live here this humble prayer
father in Jesus name I pray
amen
oh stay with me
okay okay I'll stay here would you
kindly read the question again okay this
is from a young people how do you know
that you're ready to enter into a
relationship and how do you know what
are the qualities that a woman or a man
should be looking for as a Christian
Adventist
in Genesis 2 reading from verse 21 the
Bible says and the Lord God caused the
Deep Sleep to fall upon Adam and he
slept and he took one of his ribs and
closed up the flesh instead thereof and
the rib which the Lord God had taken
from man made he a woman and brought her
unto the
man we have a man and a woman so we have
two mature people we do not have a boy
and a girl as is popular in this present
age we have a man and a woman
presupposing emotional maturity to a
certain level the requirements for
relationship one which is almost never
considered is that what God wants for
you let me explain why Jesus was not
married Paul was not married Daniel was
not married and God told Jeremiah do not
marry and do not have children Jeremiah
16 so we mustn't assume everyone has to
enter into a relationship and so
requirement one is this what God wants
from me not what Society expects of
me society says 178 have a relationship
20 get married by 25 you have seven
children that me may not be God's will
for you and this is very serious we
enter into situations into which God has
not sent
us and so requirement one God is it your
will for me that I enter into a
relationship question two with
whom with whom the requirements for the
man very general he must be a man not a
boy
one have some means of
support are you with me willing to leave
his
family why do I stress that I have
counseled many
women who complain the husband wants the
wife to be a house servant for the
mother the
mother marry a girl and give her to the
mother as a servant in the house no your
wife is not your mother's
servant and so be willing to leave your
father and your mother not abandon leave
we see this principle in nature where
after certain age animals are driven
out and so he must be willing to
leave let me say something that's not in
question it is the man who goes looking
not the
woman the Bible doesn't say this
therefore shall a woman leave her father
and mother and cl no therefore shall a
man leave he is the one who
searches are you with me all right not
the woman don't go looking for a man let
a man find you as a daughter of
God emotional man emotionally
immature uh some form of income some
place to put the woman are you following
me but above all a relationship with God
amen because that man will be a priest
not a perfect priest but a priest are
you following me don't marry a man
spiritually weaker than
you where you have to lead him to the
altar that's not God's will marry
someone spiritually stronger than you a
man in that position that he may take
the lead as the priest of the home for
the woman woman who loves to be
home and not in the mall 24 hours a day
she loves to be home her home is her
Palace and she's the queen of that house
of course number one she has a
relationship with God Amen Now ladies
who are considering marriage men who are
considering marriage read proverbs 31
10-31 there is no other document on
Earth that describes more clearly what a
desirable woman is like she's not a
woman who cannot think she's intelligent
she's assertive she can run a business
she she knows how to take care of the
home and outside the home she's a leader
in her own right she's not a
puppet or a
robot you read about Abigail in the
Bible how she saved her husband's life
when David was coming to kill him
Abigail very intelligent woman El talks
about her and so number one a
relationship with God for both mature
now keep this in mind women tend to
mature sooner than
men and so a 20-year-old lady may be
more mature than a 20-year- old man no
wonder the general uh advice is let the
man be older than the woman are you with
me nobody said amen amen was Adam older
than
Eve was Adam older than Eve yes now
that's not to say if you're 25 and a man
you cannot marry a woman who's 26 I'm
not saying that I'm simply saying the
general principle is the man is older
than the woman another good biological
reason for that is a man can father
children when he's 70 or 75 a woman
cannot do
that and so it makes biological sense to
have the woman younger particularly if
children are part of your future
and let God decide if children must be
part of your
future okay spiritual growth emotional
maturity the man must have a source of
income the woman can to the man must
have some place to put his wife and the
man must be willing to defend his
wife if the family attacks
her let me tell you why I this is what
I've encountered in my
counseling men defend their mothers
against their wives you can't do
that the closest connection on Earth is
not son and mother or son and father it
is what husband and wife you must defend
your wife against everyone except
God are you with me you cannot allow
your family to make your wife miserable
if your mother visits your mother is a
guest she doesn't run around the house
trying to take over uhuh she's a guest
your wife is in charge of that
house I'm sure you all get along but I
thought I'd throw that
out all right that's all I can say on
that by the way those of you considering
relationships read messages to young
people
please read the Adventist home and for
those of you Desiring children read
Child
Guidance please I'll give you one more
book read letters to young lovers so
therefore for those of you quing
messages to young people letters to
young lovers for those of you who
recently married or just on the verge of
marriage Advent is home and when
children are part of your Thinking Child
Guidance one more
thing and please keep a straight face I
don't want to see who's
guilty marry within your
religion amen have a few amens on this
side nothing on oh
okay let me say it again by let me say
it this way in Genesis chapter 6 the
chapter where we're introduced to the
flood and why God will send the flood
the Bible says and it came to pass when
men began to multiply on the face of the
Earth and daughters were born unto them
that the sons of God saw the daughters
of men that they were fair and they took
them wives of all which they chose they
only identified offense against God in
Genesis 6 now it does say the Earth was
filled with violence it does say that
doesn't identify but the only clearly
identified
offense is children of God marrying
children of the
world and I'll leave it right there next
question okay next question this is a
related question but uh it belongs to
someone who is married mhm if I get
married to a nonbeliever did I sin
that's the first question all right
we'll take it piece by
piece do you have your Bibles with you
yes I'll miss this side when I leave 2
Corinthians 6 second Corinthians Ians
6 now keep in mind truth is not always
Pleasant are you with me all
right you have 2 Corinthians 6 let's
read verse
14 be not unequally alt together with
unbelievers for what Fellowship hath
righteousness with unrighteousness or
what communion ha light with Darkness
now when Paul says what Fellowship has
righteousness with than righteousness or
what communion hath light with Darkness
he's quoting from Genesis 1:3 and God
said let there be light and they was
light and God saw the light that it was
good and God divided the light from the
darkness and Paul uses that creation
event to make a spiritual point when you
marry outside of your religion you
displease God
yes
mhm remember
Samson Samson saw a Philistine woman he
came to the parents get her for me the
parents said Samson can't you find an
Israelite
woman Samson said she pleases me
well God says they will take you from
me not you will bring them to me they
will take you from me and so we have to
be very careful one of the top five
reasons for marital stress is difference
in religion Plus Finance and
communication difference in
religion there's a person I
know know very
well married outside the church and
gradually
left the
church I've known more than one person
in that way gradually left the church in
attempt to please the
man mhm I have I have to please my
husband no you have to please God first
marriage cannot change that God always
remains first regardless of
circumstances it doesn't mean the
unbeliever is bad it simply means a
square peg does not fit a round hole
that's all not the person is bad a
square peg must fit a square hole next
question next question is it advisable
to Mary hold on hold on yes
huh is a sin if it displeases God it is
MHM I just wanted to be nice okay is it
advisable to marry a divorced
non-believer and Bel or believer man is
it what is it advisable to marry a
divorced believer or non-believer
man there's nothing wrong with a
divorced
person the first question is is it God's
will for me to unite with this person
because there's some divorced people who
are absolutely innocent are you
following me they have been divorced
they're innocent and the teaching of
this church is the innocent person can
remarry that's the teaching of this
church so being divorced is not a strike
against your suitability for marriage
the question is has God chosen this
person for me whether the person is
divorced or not is this God's Will and
God is willing to tell you his will will
as for the unbeliever the answer is
no okay the next question is uh if
you're hold on hold
on there is no boyfriend evangelism in
the
Bible uh-uh there's no girlfriend
evangelism God told the Israelites do
not inter marry with the Nations around
you that's what he told them plain and
straight M obeying God is Not always
easy because our minds are different
from God's minds but in the long run
it's the safest way to
live always ask yourself what are the
consequences in the long
run okay if your unbelieving partner
decided to
leave and look and live with another
woman is the
wife can file divorce or analment to
have a certificate of divorce and she
can marry
again
now if I knew these questions were of
this nature I would not have agreed stay
in my room now Customs very I understand
in the Philippines you can't divorce is
that true no you can't divorce all right
analment only well whether the
Philippines or Malaysia or wherever the
Bible is the Bible and the 7day
Adventist Church has positions it is
taken based on scripture and counsel
from Al and white if an unbelieving
partner decides to leave you there's
very little you can do are you with me
leaving you is not
divorce are you following me that may be
separation separation does not free you
to
remarry now if the person who leaves you
gets involved with someone else and
commits adultery breaks the marriage
contact you are free to marry but don't
go hoping the person does that are you
following me don't do that because God
is a god of
reconciliation but if the person
believer or Not by the way breaks the
marriage vows you the innocent party are
free to marry the guilty person must
remain unmarried that's the position of
this
church the guilty person cannot not well
should not because frequently they do
should not
remarry let me tell you something
marriage is Serious
Business it is not a social
custom it's so it's serious if you're
not 100% sure stay out of
it but that's what I mean don't get
married yes if you're not serious you
see marriage is once you're
in that's it the door is shut you can't
get
out if she ceases to cook for you you
can't leave if she get hits by a bus and
loses a beauty you cannot
leave it is
serious people marry because it's
accustomed to do everybody's marrying
Let Me Marry to why I don't look odd no
no it's better to be single and odd than
married and
miserable all right okay the next
question is is it okay for church
leaders to be a witness or Guardian in
an unequally yoke marriage will they be
held
accountable you're really trying to get
me into
trouble if the church is against mixed
marriages how can the church authorize a
minister to off iate at a mixed marriage
how the church is officially against
mixed marriages is that clear as
day the Seventh Day Adventist Church is
against mixed
marriages what oh unequally same thing
yes now an Adventist Minister May marry
a Catholic and a
Baptist because prophetically they're
the same thing
you don't understand what I'm trying to
say prophetically they're the same
thing are you following me he may marry
a Pentecostal and uh
whomever not an Adventist and a
non-adventist
what of course they held
accountable if my sister married and not
Adventist I would not go to the
wedding okay next
question the man and the woman live as a
couple yes both are separated uh-huh can
they be
baptized they live together yes but
they're not married yeah they live
together and they're not married they're
not married but they live as a couple no
no no no no they can't do
that they can't do that you live
together with your spouse are you
following me
nobody said amen amen this whole church
needs to be rebap tized nobody said amen
you live with your spouse do not allow
the standards of the world to dictate
the behavior of the church we must teach
the world not the world teach the church
you live with your wife or your husband
and if he's not your husband you live in
paranak and he may live in some other
place
soron but not in the same house are you
following
me
m why you asking question well I
shouldn't ask you that go ahead okay the
next question has something to do with
food yes if it was God's ideal that
humans consume herbs as food why did
Jesus give fish in the feeding of the
5,000 all right okay and why give meat
as food for the high priest family okay
let me pray again father as I continue
give me simple language God I really
mean that so I might answer your people
clearly and thereby glorify your name in
Jesus name I pray
amen 7th Day Adventist theology is
founded on the sanctuary
service are you following me to
understand the gospel how God forgives
how God Saves how God justifies how
Christ intercedes on our behalf we must
study the sanct AR
Services
now there was a special day in the year
called the day of
atonement on that day no meat was
brought into the most holy
place are you following me or the temple
the Tabernacle no meat was brought in on
other days 359 days of the year on some
occasions the priest would bring some
flesh into the holy place and consume
the Flesh and thereby identify with the
sinner are you with
me by eating the flesh he identifies now
no meat was consumed on the day of
atonement now the day of atonment was
held on the 10th day of the 7eventh
month that began literally October 22
1844 when Jesus moved from where the
holy place to the most holy and began
what we call what the investigative
judgment because the day of atonement
was a day of
judgment so if we take the
symbolic and help it use it to help us
understand the literal as verily as
there was no meat consumed on the day of
atonement now that we are in the
antitypical day of atonement which began
October 22 1844 the ideal lifestyle is a
lifestyle without
meat Jesus did not live in the
antitypical day of atonement are you
following me he lived in the period when
meat was still taken into the holy place
from October 22 1844 we moved into the
antitypical uh day of judgment on which
no meat was brought into the
Tabernacle tell you something else about
meat meat God
allowed people to eat meat to shorten
their
lives I'll get a quotation give it to Dr
Jim he can give it to the church he
allowed them to eat meat to shorten
their lives because God has no interest
in Sinners living living
long you see the longer you live and the
more you sin the more you suffer in a
final
destruction so God in his Mercy
shortened
life shortened the lives of Sinners one
way he did that the consumption of
meat
MH another quotation Al says most of the
cancers today are the result of flesh
eating
now how can you read that and still
subsist on
meat you must be
suicidal are you with
me but the most powerful biblical
argument is we are in the antitypical
day of atonement when no meat was
brought into the Tabernacle particularly
the most holy place which is where we
are now no
meat that's the historical period in
which we are we should avoid meat like
the plague now let me say
this if you decide to eat just on your
birthday some Lapu Lapu on your your
birthday I am not sending you to
hell are you with me but Adam only had
one bite of an animal of a of of an
apple and look what
happened one little thing can lead to
something else the best thing to do is
total avoidance if you can but don't run
around people people trying to judge
them because God gives people victory at
different stages in their
lives we have several spiritual gifts
the gift of knowledge wisdom healing
Miracles there is no gift of
policing amen am I getting through to
God's people there are too many church
members who are
police and they watch you let me go to
Luke 14 quickly let's read verse one go
go to Luke
14:1 a lot of policemen in the
church they watch you they watch you and
they try to arrest you do you have Luke
14 1 okay and it came to pass as he ENT
into one the house of one of the chief
Pharisees to eat bread on the Sabbath
day finish the verse that they watched
it the Pharisees and scribes were always
watching Jesus to catch him
I go to many homes for lunch and all my
travels and dinner and they gave me what
I want they eat meat we
pray are you with me we
pray I pass no judgment
none
none all
right how about what fish fish is
meat
yeah fish is
meat he was not in the period which we
now call the day of
atonement in that period meat was
brought into the sanctuary that's the
period in which Jesus lived are didn't I
make that
clear in this period from 1844 we are in
the most holy place period no meat was
brought in all right I was in a certain
country you asked about fish and I went
to someone's house for dinner and that
the person's I said uh I'm a vegetarian
he said oh okay bringing some
fish bringing some fish I said wait a
minute a fish has a face you know a fish
has parents you
know okay next question what does the
Bible say about those who rather than go
to church building during Sabbath go to
other places to conduct small group
meetings worship like coffee shops malls
Parks Mountain Etc to reach out Souls
okay Satan is very
clever we have to be very careful with
the decisions we make which we call Soul
winning you have seven days in the week
to go to the coffee shop are you with me
you have Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday and
Sunday you have SE days to go where to
the mall and to the beach and to borai
and to have your services to win
Palawan to win whomever on the Sabbath
day come together in church are you with
me go to Hebrews chapter
10 go to Hebrews 10 my good sister you
know you're slow today you're
slow you're slow
today oh this is a tragedy my sister say
slow all right Hebrews chapter 10 amen
let's read verse 25 what does it
say not forsaking the assembling of
yourselves together as the manner of
some is but exalting one another come on
finish the verse so much the more as you
see the day approaching do not forsake
the assembling of
yourselves
now during Co
crisis people met in houses that's the
way the church met in the days of the
Apostles there were no church buildings
if you read the New Testament you find
the church in this person's house
filimon 1:2 the church in thine house
Colossians 4:15 the church in his house
they met in houses Church buildings
became common beginning in the days of
Constantine because he became converted
in quotation mark and then he
contributed funds for church building
projects but prior to that people met in
houses in the Bible there were three
feasts where all men had to come I think
it was Tabernacles Passover and uh there
was another one that SLI my mind they
were to all come to Jerusalem not in
their
houses they had to go to Jerusalem to
the temple and assembled on the day of
atonement everyone came around the
temple not in their tents everyone came
around the temple fasting afflicting
their souls confessing Sins not working
and coming together for worship those
two four things coming together for
worship not working confessing sins
fasting those four things distinguish
behavior on the day of atonement those
four things should distinguish Us in
this part of the church's history not
that you don't go to work but work does
not become a priority a Readiness for
God becomes your priority you work in
the context of expressing righteousness
and so if you can come to the church
come the devil loves isolated people and
isolated
groups M you see that in nature a lion
prefers to attack an isolated Buffalo
than go into the
herd same for cheetah same for hyena
they look for isolated pray old young
sick injured isolated that's where and
Satan the Bible says as a roaring lion
walketh about seeking whom he may devour
and the isolated person is easier for
Satan to
conquer if you can come to church come
because your presence May bless someone
else
yes ask the Dr
Jim come
here Pastor come here
come Pastor is it okay for the medical
professionals to go on duty during
Sabbath all right let's take that mic
from real quickly before she has
anything else more embarrassing can we
just give our okay all right I got you I
got you I got you I got thank you I got
you there's a medical professional right
here he may have a gun I don't know now
medical Ministry page 216 paragraph 2
what did I
sayic page 216 paragraph ly says it may
be necessary for the medical
professional to go to the hospital but
that person must only do what is
necessary to ease suffering and the
money he or she earns must be given to
the church
amen medical Ministry page 216 paragraph
2 I didn't say that El white said that
let me say it again it you see Jesus
said it is lawful to do good on the
Sabbath it is lawful to heal on the
Sabbath he never said it is lawful to
work because it was he who said among
Sinai in it Thou shalt not do any work
but he approves doing good and saving
life is doing good easing suffering is
doing good earning money is not doing
good on the
Sabbath and so El councils give the
money to the
church let me leave that alone quickly
amen you see some people prefer to work
on Sabbath well in United States because
the pay on Sabbath is more than during
the week
double and so they say well I'm a doctor
I can go in the Angels don't mind no no
God reads
this mhm he reads
this the fact that you're doctor or
nurse doesn't mean you're free to work
you should do everything you can to
avoid going in but if you have to you
follow El's counsel once you make
exceptions for one group then the
fireman comes and says well can I work
on Sabbath then the policeman comes and
says can I work on Sabbath then whomever
the the gyy driver can I work on
Sabbath it's dangerous to make
exceptions to God's law you open the
flood gates to all kinds of exceptions a
man may say well in the Philippines
there are 10 women to one man can I have
two wives I'll be doing them a
favor you cannot make
exceptions serving God is Serious
Business uh patri and Prophets page 479
paragraph 2 El white WR go writes God
shut Moses out of Canaan to teach a
lesson which should never be forgotten
that he requires exact
obedience councils for the church page
268 paragraph 5 ELO white WR the history
of God's dealing with his people in all
ages shows that he demands
strict
obedience if you're going in for brain
surgery don't you want the surgeon to
follow strict
principles
yes mhm he's cutting up your
head you want him to do everything right
every little detail has to be
right God is the same way next question
thank you okay next question is can
rebaptism really needed is can rebaptism
be done to come back say it again say it
again rebaptism rebaptism yeah yes is it
important to come back to God is it re
yes yes yes yes yes yes in the book of
Acts chapter
19 read verses 1-7 Paul met 12 disciples
Who had bapti who were baptized by
John's baptism Paul said I think verse
three have you received the Holy Ghost
since you've been baptized they said
we've never heard whether there be any
Holy Ghost then said Paul unto what then
were you baptized you said John's
baptism then Paul explained more fully
and the Bible says verse 5 they were
baptized yes they were re-baptized
evangelism page 375 paragraph 2 when a
man is truly reconverted or a soul man
or woman let that person be rebap tized
let him renew his Covenant with God and
God will renew knew his Covenant with
him
reconversion must take place in the
churches there are many church members
who got
wet but were not
baptized baptism is a spiritual event
that uh sacramentally connects you to
Christ know you not that so many of you
as were baptized into Christ have put on
Christ Galatians 3:27 so many of us have
been baptized into Christ have been
baptized into his death Romans 6:3 it's
a serious
Sacrament and without it you have
offended the procedure that Christ has
laid out yes baptism and rebaptism are
required now if you are a paraplegic
then the baptism of Jesus covers
you but if you can go into that water go
and start all over mhm
okay there are children who've been
baptized just to bapti get baptized with
their friends others have been baptized
because the parents forced them that is
not a
baptism others are baptized not knowing
what they were doing that's not a
baptism when you come to the point of
realizing what baptism means you ought
to be
baptized can B can baptism be done even
if they were not finished yet with
the uh lessons you don't have to study
all the lessons to be
baptized you see the longer you put it
off the less likely you are to do it a
conviction has a
lifespan are you with me as you put it
off the conviction gets weak yes and the
devil is so tricky he tells you study
more study more study more know
everything is not necessary
do you know God wants you to keep the
Ten Commandments do you believe he wants
you to keep the Sabbath do you be have
do you believe he has a Remnant Church
on
Earth you can learn the rest listen to
Matthew 28:19 go ye therefore and teach
All Nations baptizing them in the name
of the Father the Son the Holy Ghost
teaching them so we have teach baptize
teach not teach everything before
baptism that's not necess
necessary give them the essentials the
spinal cord of the truth then later on
you can put on the
ribs okay when Adam and Eve were created
are they aware that the Ten Commandments
exist ah good question when Adam and Eve
were created were they aware The Ten
Commandments exist they had a knowledge
of the law of God
yes that's
why when Eve went
when Eve spoke to the serpent he said
God said do not you see in the Bible the
person you listen to is your
god so God told Moses I will make you a
God to Pharaoh why and Aaron will be
your
prophet in other words Moses will tell
Pharaoh what to do Moses would also tell
Aaron because Moses did not speak
well Moses left Egypt for many many
years in the wilderness 40
according to El white he had lost the
ability to speak the Egyptian language
very well you see and so it's Aaron that
did all the talking but Moses told him
what to say and then he told
Pharaoh are you listening to
me Moses will tell Pharaoh uh Aaron take
up some dust toss it then Aaron will do
it so Aaron was the speaker Moses just
gave the orders so the person whose
voice you obey is your
God yes uh what question was I
answering what was the question is rism
is it is
it oh Adam and Eve yes yes yes yes yes
yes they had a consciousness of right
and wrong now before the law was spoken
on Sinai and before sin the law existed
by
principle now you have to listen
carefully Father in Heaven Help me to
make this as simple as ABC in Jesus name
I pray
amen here's a young woman who just got
married two years later she has her
first
child does she need a law from the
government to tell her breastfeed that
child no does she need a law from the
government to tell her take care of that
child no
why she loves the child the maternal
Instinct are you with me that's a
principle because because of sin someone
had to write Thou shalt breastfeed thy
child are you following me because of
sin now the Sabbath day began at
Eden the Sabbath day not the Sabbath
principle the Sabbath principle is
dependence on
God you're just looking at me I'm not
sure what to think when you look at me
like
that the Sabbath principle is I depend
on God whether I am an eagle a man an
angel a blade of grass or an Amber I
depend on God that's the Sabbath
principle when God made Adam and Eve
there was already sin in the universe
Lucifer no longer wanted to depend on
God he wanted to be God so God
instituted a
day to highlight the principle are you
following me so one a day in the week
stop all you were doing to sustain
yourself and remind yourself I am the
one who sustains
you so the day began at Eden the
principle
always
existed and so Adam and Eve had a
consciousness of right and wrong mhm
that's why when they sinned they hid
because the sense of guilt came up they
knew they had violated so they hid but
you cannot hide from God someone is
motioning to you Dr
Jim you have a
question okay I'll finish this first
okay the next question is uh what do you
mean by judgment begin at the house of
God Romans um 1 Peter 4:1
17 judgment must begin at the house of
God if you read Ezekiel
9 where Ezekiel has a vision of a
destroying
Angel God tells the angel or The Angels
Take Your swords begin at my
temple because to whom much is given
much is required much is required and
God's church has more knowledge than any
other body on the face of the Earth and
so judgment begins where the greatest
responsibilities are expected that's the
Church of God the house of God and so
judgment begins at the house of God
yes with us who should have known better
then the unbeliever or whomever who had
just a scanty knowledge of God judgment
begins at the house of
God
MH 1 Peter 4:17
yeah this is a related question uh about
the Ten Commandments M which of the Ten
Commandments was violated when Adam and
Eve disobeyed all right I touched on
that God said in the day thou eatest
thereof that's what God Said the serpent
said he shall not surely die God said
one thing the serpent said something
else whose word did they
choose that was their
God the go Exodus 7 go to Exodus
7 read verse
one my good sister on the left who
usually finds it
first all right read verse verse one
Exodus
7 and the Lord said unto
ahuh see I have made thee a God to and
Aaron thy brother shall be thy now how
was Moses a God to
Pharaoh now this is symbolic of course
through Moses and Aaron God is
displaying the relationship between him
and his servants Moses you're the god
Aaron you're the prophet you're God to
Pharaoh he was also God to
Aaron who was
older
Aaron but when God wanted to make
clothes for Aaron he told Moses what to
make not Aaron Moses represented God
Aaron his Prophet why was Moses God for
Aaron and God for Pharaoh because Moses
told
them let my people go or tell Aaron do
this do that the person you
obey is your
god and so they violated commandment one
and commandment two because Thou shalt
have no other gods Before Me by agreeing
with the serpent Eve put Satan ahead of
God in that brief period by agreeing
says Eve Adam put Eve ahead of God and
so God said in verse 17 of Genesis 3 and
unto Adam he said because thou Hast
hearkened unto the voice of thy wife and
not to my voice cursed is the ground for
thy sake by the way never put your
spouse ahead of God now this is tough
but don't the greatest favor you can do
your spouse is to keep God
first the greatest favor you can do your
family is to keep God
first he's saying amen as though you
have a headache
but put God ahead of father mother
husband wife children career job wealth
everything
it's a safe Life to Live you do your
children a favor by putting God ahead of
them you endanger them by putting them
ahead of
God you endanger the eternal life you
damage the spirituality of your spouse
by putting her above
God next question how do we know that
the SDA Doctrine is remains its purity
how do we know what that the SDA
Doctrine maintains its Purity
oh but at some point we have to put a
stop to this flow of
questions the Seventh Day Adventist
Church teaches something called present
truth are you with
me there's a lot of Truth in the Bible
that Pleasant truth our focus is present
truth victory over sin the Divinity of
Christ the humanity of Christ uh the
seven day Sabbath the perpetuity of the
law the validity of the
Sabbath all of that present truth the
Judgment in heaven present truth the
second coming present
truth all our present truth doctrines
are as they have been developed and they
have not been surrendered by by the
church now are there members in the
church that have their own views
yes the early Christian Church was
founded by Jesus
Christ you know what he said of his
church and he was the pastor here's what
he said John 6:7 have I not chosen you
12 one of you is a
devil now here is a church pastored by
Jesus one member was a
devil and he wasn't the church if Jesus
can Pastor a church that had a devil
surely someone can Pastor passai knowing
in passai you finish it Dr
[Laughter]
Jim our doctrines are the same they have
not changed but some members go all off
north south east and west with all kinds
of false doctrines our doctrines are the
same we just need to read the 28
fundamental doctrines not listen to
people how did Sin started in heaven
when it
was that's a
mystery the reason it's a mystery
Lucifer was the closest being to God
Lucifer was made as much like God as God
could make him the faith I live by Page
66 paragraph 2 God made him good and
beautiful as near as possible like
himself he was next to Christ in
character and exaltation the Le the
person least likely to sin should have
been
Lucifer he's the one who sined it is a
mystery in the Bible not
explained because the moment you explain
sin you excuse it so we do not know what
led to it all we know is it began in
that being called Lucifer Ezekiel 28:15
thou was perfect in thy the ways in the
day that thou was created till iniquity
was found in thee he was perfect until
sin was found in him and we will have to
understand how that happened when we
meet God when he comes back and he's
coming back by the way but it's a
mystery that that being could sin
against his God to whom he was so
close next question by the way sorry Dr
Jim who tried to kill Christ in
heaven
Lucifer who seduced Adam to
sin his
wife who killed
Abel who killed Abel what was the
relationship his brother who told
Abraham go sleep with
Hagar his wife who deceived Isaac when
he was blind his wife and his son one my
try who betrayed Christ a disciple
your greatest enemy is the person close
to
[Music]
you
mm personally and on the church level
listen to me the greatest enemy of
Adventist are former
Adventists mhm oh yes ELO says we have
more to fear from within than
without
m
next question next question are there a
other Adam and Eve in other planets oh
good question are there other Adams and
EES on other
planets oh okay how do we handle such
people we remember first of all God
still loves them and some people drift
and come back the same way God is long
suffering always Desiring The Sinner to
come back we must try to adopt the same
attitude without sustaining them in what
they're doing or allowing their behavior
to contaminate us but at no time can we
decide that person is cut off only God
can cut you off we must pray be
Christians be Christlike be loving but
never endorse whatever they're doing and
don't allow them to affect us but always
believe God may bring that person back
God finally converted Paul no one would
have guessed that could happen God
finally converted
Nebuchadnezzar people do come back God
gives a second chance we must be willing
to do the same so let's not put
ourselves on a pedestal and look down on
people but we're not sharing in their
behavior in their false beliefs but
we're praying that God will open their
eyes and bring them back
mhm okay this is a very interesting
question a lot of soul winning has to be
done in the
church mhm there are people in the pews
but out of Christ a lot of soul winning
needs to occur in the church before we
bring someone else from the outside in
all right Dr Jim okay this is a very
interesting question if you plan to
commit suicide yes can you ask for
forgiveness before committing
it
next
question that's uh I hope no one is
planning
that my brothers and sisters the Bible
says in 1 Corinthians 6:20 for you
bought with a price he not your own you
cannot prepay on forgiveness are you
with me you do that on a cell phone you
cannot prepay you top up for forgiveness
then go commit a
crime no he can't do that just do not
commit
suicide whatever you're facing go to God
he is a specialist in making the
impossible possible do not take your
life God can turn it around he really
can how about euthanasia how about what
euthanasia euthanasia
yeah
yes life belongs to
God no human being is authorized to just
take life unless that Authority comes
from God life belongs to God and God may
allow the person to be ill to change
you you didn't get what I said the Lord
may allow someone in your family to be
seriously ill in order to reach you and
change
you and so we just can't go around
deciding kill him kill him mercy killing
mercy killing sounds nice and merciful
euthanasia sounds fancy but life belongs
to God are you with me and God can put
an end when he's ready what we cannot
change or fix we trust God Christ was on
the cross suffering bleeding from his
skin in the Garden of Gethsemane there
was no mercy killing for him he suffered
and suffered and suffered and ELO tells
us he tasted death for every
man the punishment of every person
whoever confessed sins W Christ he
suffered it no mercy killing for him all
right okay next question is obedience
righteousness by works obedience is not
righteousness by works obedience is the
only way to show love for God what does
the Bible say if you love
me yes is the only way to show love
obedience it's as simple as that
obedience is love with
shoes it's not righteousness by works
there's no such thing to qualify you for
heaven what qualifies us for Heaven is
righteousness by faith and it EXP
expresses itself in works that please
God let's go to the chapter that we call
the fifth chapter huh let's look at
Faith and words by faith able offered we
have faith we have Works verse 7 by
faith Noah being warned of God of things
not seen as yet move with fear prepared
an ark by faith then we have the works
by faith Abraham when he's called to go
out into a land which is should have
receive for inheritance obeyed by faith
he did that by faith so we have this
Faith work Faith work in the Hebrews 11
there's no such thing as faith faith and
nothing else that's a dead Faith Faith
Works and so James tells us in James
2:26 for as the body without the spirit
is dead so faith without works is dead
also and he took that from Genesis 1 uh
2:7 and the Lord God form man of the
Dust of the ground breathe into his
nostrils of bre Breath of Life and Man
became a living Soul it is works that
prove your faith is alive if you're
walking down the street and you see
someone lying on the ground how will you
determine if the person is alive what
would you
do what would you
do check his pulse what
else see if he's breathing what else is
his heartbeating what are those things
called Vital
Signs works are vital signs
that faith is
alive is
cremation sin is cremation sin
no absolutely
not you can't sin by burning
dirt are you with me let me speak
respectfully but
bluntly we are
dirt
when Adam s what did God say to him
Genesis 3:17 and unto Adam he said
because thou Hast hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife and Hast eaten of the
tree of which I commanded thee saying
Thou shalt not eat of it curs is the
ground for thy sake in sorrow shalt thou
eat of it all the days of thy life
Thorns also and thistles shall I bring
forth unto thee and thou shalt eat the
herb of the field in the sweat of thy
face shallal thou eat bread till thou
return unto the ground for out of it was
thou taken for dust Thou Art he called
him dirt while he was
alive when you die you're double
dirt cremation is burning dirt but we
get so emotionally attached and I
understand that are you following me
because you still see your cousin that's
not dirt that's my
cousin but after a few days you're not
standing there unless you do
this is your cousin my father's dead my
mother's dead my brother brother's dead
my father-in-law is dead my
mother-in-law is dead my favorite cousin
is dead a niece is dead I understand
death but they're
dirt you have to understand they are
dirt when I die if I die before Christ
come take any organ that's in good
shape are you with me I am dirt I want
my
does I want know all right go ahead Dr
Jim okay this is a very personal
question Pastor Randy the question is
how long have you been memorizing the
scripture and what prompted you to do it
oh very simple and quick as a little boy
I became an Adventist there was a custom
in the church to memorize a verse every
day all of us did it all the young
people a new verse every day and we
would cited those verses at the Young
people's service in the afternoon
everybody came young and old it was just
just a lifestyle that's
all nothing fancy but I grew up doing it
it stayed with me and the Lord has
convicted me that's what I want you to
do and so I do it whether I have to
preach on I just do it all day all day
all
day I'm on the plane I'm saying it I go
to the bathroom I recite I brush my
teeth I recite something I uh in the gym
what I do in the gym go to the gym let's
say you're doing some bicep curls you do
a set for you rest for 60 seconds you
recite Bible verses don't just stand
there no recite something so what I do
is no I'm serious what I do is I time
myself with a stopwatch how long would
Revelation 15 which is just 8 verses and
30 seconds and so I say it twice that's
60 seconds rest on 90 seconds say three
times there lot of little Psalms you can
just recite are you following me you do
that while you're resting or recovering
then you go back you come off the
machine you recite
again you use your time wisely mhm yeah
yeah no don't recite while you're doing
this you got to concentrate are you
following when you're off the machine
and you're trying to recover
recite by the way anyone can do
that do you know the Bible commands us
to use our
memory
where recite the fourth Commandment for
me stop what does that first word
say how can you remember if you don't
use your memory we are commanded to use
our
memory remember the Sabbath
day all right forsake not the assembling
don't
forget you see the Bible says Thy word
have I hid where in my heart why
ah listen to this
quotation why is it that so many of our
youth and even those of more mature
years are so easily led into temptation
and sin the reason is the word of God is
Not studied and meditated upon as it
should Ela tells us that M that's why we
fall into
sin you see there's coming a time when
we won't have
this I travel a lot and many many years
ago I told god father if you're looking
for someone to go to Islamic country at
like to go and so I started putting this
in here so if I go through customs and
they say do you have a Bible I can say
no I don't have one physically but I
have one here amen you can't confiscate
what's in
here are you with me Dr Jim you cannot
confiscate what's in here you can
confiscate my hand luggage my shoe you
cannot confiscate the word that's hidden
here
here all right let's get off that yes
next question okay by the way start one
verse at a time it's not that
hard yes 1 Thessalonians 51 17 pray
without ceasing did you just memorize
that
yes you know one verse John 11:35 Jesus
wept now you know
two just that quickly you know too all
right okay the next question is uh have
you experienced persecution from our
church yes and so how have you manag so
far oh I just
laughed I just
laughed I have been blocked some places
for preaching I won't call it
persecution because yeah but I go some I
I went to a certain country to preach
and they stopped
it they say he can't come but I had to
go to the country because from that
country I had to go to Malaysia for
youth conference so I had to be there so
I arrived and hey you can't preach they
gave me no reason I said fine I don't
fight the church I don't do that my
policy is if the church asks you to do
something you cannot show it's a
Biblical sin and it does not offend your
conscience try to
cooperate because God set up a citiz a
system of leadership for reason God set
up leadership is originated in heaven
one person above somebody else I believe
in OB obing the church unless the church
asks me to commit a sin or requires
something that directly violates my
conscience if those two things are not
present I obey are you with me if it's a
local Elder leading a church under a
tree and he tells me something I
obey so when I got to this country they
said you can't preach I said
fine and then I met with the conference
president the very next day and he EXP
explain he thought I was the problem he
realized I wasn't he apologized and he
said Elder SK you can come back anytime
I said thank you he gave me a nice
vegetarian hug and that was the end of
that then I went to another country to
preach for a crusade and the night The
Crusade was to begin they canceled it
they said you cannot preach so I called
the conference office the next day I
said what's the problem they said it's
not you the people who invited you did
not follow protocol okay I I left flew
back home a few weeks later they wrote
me we are so sorry we handle this badly
please come back I went back priest had
a lovely time so that's the way I handle
opposition if you tell me no I Don't
Preach you tell me yes I preach and
that's
it I have a
policy no one can keep you out of the
place where God wants you to be and no
one can put you where God does not want
you to be so I leave it to
him How Will I
Know led by The Spirit Well we if the
church leaders require actions that are
anti-biblical and contrary to the the
the policies of the church then we have
a problem but don't sit around judging
leaders you see Al said we become like
the sins look
for so if you're looking trying to judge
leaders that's a dangerous thing to do
because you'll see what you're looking
for even if it doesn't exist you'll see
it our first duty is to pray for our
leaders and we don't do that my policy
is if I haven't been praying for you I'm
not criticizing you that's my policy if
I have not been praying for you I'm in
the last in the line to criticize you
because if I had prayed perhaps that
would not have
happened I don't criticize those for
whom I have not prayed
M try as much as possible to cooperate
with your
leaders and pray for them because the
devil works hard on them the Bible says
Smite the shepherd what happened you
scatter the Sheep so they're under
tremendous pressure and attack and the
last thing they need is attacked from
the members pray for them and remember
they're not
perfect okay next question is is it okay
to conduct a choir practice or church
board meeting Before Sunset of
Sabbath H Father in Heaven as I continue
give me wisdom I pray in Jesus name
amen there are seven days in the
week are they still seven yes did they
cut it down to four you have Sunday
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and
Friday use one of those leave the
Sabbath alone the problem is you see we
we we think we give God the
Sabbath but we tell him the rest of the
six days we giving you
nothing we give you the Sabbath you
better be happy but you see
God wants time during the week too God
says give me a tithe which is specific
then he says give me an offering which
is up to you the tithe the Sabbath is
specific how much time we give him
during the week is up to
us I went to a church to preach in
certain country on the face of the
Earth and when I got to the pulpit I
said is everyone in the church who
should be in the church they said no I
said what do you mean they said there
there's a choir rehearsing
downstairs I said oh I said I want two
deacons who are not afraid to do their
work to go down and tell that choir to
come up and I sat
down couple minutes later the choir came
up they sat down I said nice to see you
we missed you then I prayed I preached a
few weeks later the choir Master wrote
me an email why did you ask the choir to
come
up so I wrote back very nicely a friend
of my he said Randy if he had written
that to
me I would have written an acidic letter
back to him that he would have to ask me
why call a choir upstairs you see if the
choir rehearses during church service
why can't the path finders rehearsed dur
in church
service don't open the door to
trouble are you with me do not make
exceptions then every everybody wants to
practice on
Sabbath you have six days give God some
time during the
week all seven days belong to him really
are you understanding me all seven
belong to him all 100 pesos belong to
him now 10 tithe you decide the offering
but all belong to him and he can take
it leave the Sabbath
alone that includes weddings and
funerals as much as possible
how about but if I have to pick one I'd
pick the funeral to have on Sabbath
because you're solemn you know your the
wedding no I've never been to a wedding
where Christ was the
focus it's always a bride not Christ and
the bride is her
dress not Christ are you with me I have
never seen a wedding where Christ was
the four well there was one that came
very close about 4 years ago go and I
was
surprised mhm there was a little sermon
little service prayer and then I I never
seen
that Dr Jim how about medical Mission
and the Sabbath as church as part of
church
visitation what what does that mean are
you do medical Outreach on the Sabbath
what is involved in medical
Outreach did
did Jesus
Christ let us go to Mark 6 come on come
on my sister you should have that by now
you're getting slow getting slow Mark 6
okay read verse 31 listen
carefully and he said unto them come
yourselves
apart into a desert place and rest a
while
[Music]
why yes so that they had no time so much
as to eat now the disciples were working
hard under the direction of Christ
Christ said wait a minute let's get away
from this let's go somewhere in the
desert where they can't find us of
course they found him but he said let's
go to Desert place even good works you
need a
break H I said we need to take a break
even from spiritual
work
medical missionary work on the
Sabbath it's lawful to do good on the
Sabbath don't take that to
extremes because is it good to sweep the
streets of passai if they're dirty yes
are you going to do it on Sabbath but
it's a good
work is it good to give a shower to the
guy who's Dirty on the streets of
paranak yes why do it on Sabbath you
have 6 days to take care of the world
can you leave God's Sabbath alone as as
much as possible I'm not saying don't do
good I'm saying don't go to
extremes on
Sabbath we use the Sabbath to protect
our six days you see we use the Sabbath
so we put everything on Sabbath to
protect the six days from God's
interference God reads this not
these how about observing the Sabbath
only in the morning doing what observing
the Sabbath in the morning uhhuh and
sleeping in the whole afternoon of
Sabbath
okay ah you have some strange
problems
okay there's nothing wrong with sleeping
on the Sabbath we sleep 7 days a week
the Bible doesn't say stay up all
Sabbath you can
sleep but since it's a special day you
can make special considerations for that
day and spend more time up serving God
than snoring are you with me and so we
we remember it is a special day it is
God's
day and we make that the basis from
which we approach what we'll do but
surely it's not a sin to sleep on
Sabbath no no but don't sleep to escape
some of the thing you can do for God's
glory on the Sabbath
because you don't sleep through work or
you'll be fired you don't do
that about intimate moments during
Sabbath oh
lord well I don't know about that
because I'm a vegetarian but
anyway go to uh Exodus
19 intimate moments on the
Sabbath okay
yeah verse
now listen carefully listen to Moses
giving instructions to the Israelites in
preparation for God who was coming down
on si in chapter 20 he's getting
instructions in chapter 19 here is what
Moses tells the Israelites verse 15
Exodus 19 what does that
say and he said unto the people be ready
against the third day come not at your
wives not come not at your
girlfriend's come not at your
wives leave off sexual relations Moses
says that was a
command and they had to do it because if
they hadn't
obeyed the church has a right to pry
into your personal life to a certain
degree ah I got one isolated lonely amen
I appreciate it listen to
me there's a sermon I preach called
invasion of
privacy the church has a right to stick
its nose in your personal business up to
a certain degree amen if there's spousal
abuse going on in the church the church
has to intervene and if nothing happens
bring in the
authorities before somebody gets killed
mhm there's some Sabbath school teacher
abusing the children some pedophile the
church has to
act before the pastor ends up in prison
for allowing that on the church property
the church has a right to get into your
business to a certain degree if your
life is disgraceful to the standards of
the church and so when it comes to
intimate relations on Sabbath I simply
say again you have Sunday Monday Tuesday
when nobody does that 6 days a week
nobody who begins that with opening
prayer are you with me
nobody your mind is not on steps to
Christ on the second coming
no it may be ordained by God that does
not make it
holy because work was ordained by God
but were not to do it on Sabbath
nobody's with me amen did God ordain
work is work a good thing are we to do
it on Sabbath no there's some things God
has ordained that should not be done on
Sabbath so don't tell me sexual
relations between husband or wife is a
holy thing I can do it any time I'm not
convinced you have
Sunday all the way through Friday huh
and and if you chose those six days to
do that you'll be happy when the Sabbath
comes are you following me all right yes
okay uh how do you minister to
lgbtq how what is a stand of the church
okay let me ask let me ask you this how
do you minister to a
fornicator how do you minister to an
adulterer how do you minister to someone
who's stealing the church money on the
treasury committee how do you minister
minister to someone blatantly working on
Sabbath how do you minister to a member
who's a drug
addict how do you minister to a
sinner
[Music]
LGB I know I'm not disrespectful but
this thing gets getting longer and
longer and if you don't know all the
letters people walk outside your house
with placers down with randis or
whatever but whatever
lb God loves all of
them are you with me he wants all of
them
saved he doesn't like the
lifestyle but he loves the People The
Church Must demonstrate that love
without tolerating the lifestyle are you
following me
now there are sins then there are
Abominations are there degrees of
sin
yes some sins have worse consequences
than others
now if I lust have I committed adultery
in my heart come on answer me can the
woman get
pregnant
no are you with me can I catch a a
disease by lust
no consequences vary among sins but I
can still be lost if not confessed if I
haven't confessed now I said there sins
the
Abominations if a man and a woman
unmarried become involved
that's a sin but physically it's a
natural
act you didn't get what I said it is a
sin spiritually but physically it's a
natural act because God arranged for a
man and a woman to perform that act but
in marriage now under no circumstance is
it all right for a man and a man to do
that under no circumstance because it is
not
natural a woman a woman it is not
natural not among human beings or among
animals and so we have
sins we have
Abominations but God wants to sa for
everyone you must never forget that and
where sin abounds Grace does much more
about we have to let all people know
regardless of the lifestyle they follow
that offends God we don't stand for this
but we want you
saved you have to apply that to your
children you have a 20-year-old boy in
your house who taking drugs smoking
gambling he has to find somewhere else
to
live before he corrupts the other
children by the way in the Old
Testament ah the Old
Testament if a boy was disobedient and
rebellious
he was brought to the elders and they
stoned him to
death in order to save the others from
his
influence did you hear what I said he
was to be brought by the parents to the
elders this boy is rebellious they
stoned him to
death so that he does not affect those
younger than him in a household the
Bible is a serious book but that doesn't
happen now but I'm trying to show you
God wanted sin put away from his people
put sin
away now what is popular in the church
should not be pop popular in the world
should not be popular in it by the way
the church must also believe that a
person with that preference can be
changed now there are laws on many books
in the United States that make it
illegal legal to practice uh conversion
therapy which is trying to make a
homosexual straight there are laws
against it you can go to
jail but the Bible tells us With God all
things are mhm the blood of Christ has
power to fix any
problem MH and the church above any
other social organization must believe
that God's power can change that
person next
question you are if you have a son or
daughter whose girlfriend is an
unbeliever what do you do as a parent I
tell them as a parent that has to stop
immediately immediately and I have to
ask myself how did I allow that to
happen what was I doing IM
immediately plain and straight putting
down your foot is sometimes a Christian
thing to do no no no no no but if I had
a son or daughter which I don't have
hopefully I would have raised them in
such a way that could never ever
happen next question
yes now oh can I take that okay we have
an Adventist boy or young man but the
two parents don't
agree don't respect your parents
view mhm don't fight your parents put it
before God respect you see when you
marry you marry into a
family are you following
me what if
what yeah well the boy may want it the
girl may want it yes I understand that
we're all hard-headed
but you can't think of what I want now
we have to think of 10 years down Road
15 if something goes wrong the first
place you have to turn are to those
family
members so you cannot say I'm a man I'm
20 I'm a woman I'm 19 I'll do what I
like no matter what my parents say you
have Christian parents listen to them if
they don't like it now
okay go to God God knows how to change
minds and hearts but don't become an
example of rebellion I don't care what
my parents say I don't care what his
parents M don't do that
don't do that you say father I love him
he loves me he's a Christian I
am intervene and in the meantime respect
your
parents I'm not saying your parents are
God but God arranged a system of parents
he made two adults everyone else comes
as a child under parents that's God's
arrangement I uh many years ago I was
working in a medical school as a
counselor and a couple came to me
one was a Jew one was a Hindu they
wanted to marry the boy was a Jew the
girl was a Hindu two lovely students I
really like them a lot I think of them
quite often by the way and uh both sides
said
uh-uh and so the young people were just
what are we going to do so they came to
my office and we were
talking and eventually the two sides
came together to
talk and they eventually
agreed and and the marriage took place
they were so happy they invited me but I
couldn't go but initially the Jewish
side said no the the the uh the uh the
uh the Hindu side said
uh-uh but after a while with
communication they
agreed do not
disregard your
parents they can see what you cannot see
now sometimes parents are unreasonable I
know
you don't like the boy because he drives
a bus and he's not a doctor are you with
me or you don't like the girl because
whatever but still do everything you can
to respect your parents wishes and to
give consideration to the Views do all
you can knowing that God is watching and
God has the power to overrule but don't
rush off and do whatever you like and
tell your parents I don't care what you
think no don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't do that here's a
nice person who's raising her
hand regardless of
age
okay
okay the lady is saying what if the boy
is 40 and the girl is 60 or whatever it
is now that make that brings in a
difference yes yes when you're 17 1819
you're still on the verge of adulthood
when you're 40 and 45 that's a
difference story no no no no that's a
different story altogether you do what
you think is best no parents are parents
but you have to live your life are you
with me you have to live your life
what's
that I'm not saying there's a precise
limit but a 40-year-old man ah come on
H oh the age difference between the
couple ah can I answer that yeah
okay
when does this thing
stop Adam was made before Eve so Adam
was slightly older all right the general
principle is the man should be older
than the woman there are two good
reasons emotionally women mature quick
than men and of course reproductively a
man has a longer lifespan of
reproductivity than the woman has you
know women keep saying my clock is
ticking a man never says that are you
with me his clock ticks forever
and so generally the man should be
older but on occasion you may have a
difference where the woman is older now
the difference in that direction depends
on how old you are now if you're an
18-year-old girl or if you're a
20-year-old girl uh a young
lady a young man at 22 you don't want to
marry a woman who's
32 are you with me because when you're
42 she looked
[Laughter]
like she looked like whatever okay and
so you have to consider now if you were
50 H and she's 56 no problem are you
with me as you get older problems
disappear some problems but if you're a
20-y old boy you don't need a 26y old
woman or 27 uhuh uh-uh
uhuh n your 21y old girl you get some 25
26y old boy or or man but the general
principle is the man older than the
woman General but their
exceptions all right and even if the man
is older the Gap has to be
watched so if the girl is 24 you don't
need the man to be
44 are you following me okay so you but
there are Exceptions there are you read
the writings of Al White there are
exceptions where she uh she she she she
she approved of a marriage with a 30-y
old Gap one with a 20-some gap she
approved individual cases but her
General principle is the man younger
than the woman sorry the uh woman
younger than the man all right okay next
question can we use images of God uhhuh
in our church images of God similar to
what the Roman
Catholic that is a controversial point
should you have uh what those what those
windows called
um where you stained glass windows it's
a problem in churches because of that I
would avoid
them I have no problem personally but
I'm not your God but for some people
it's a m some people have a problem if a
church has a
steeple some Adventists faint if you
have a Christmas
tree and so you try to avoid that which
causes controversy which is not
necessary
but the church has no standing position
as far as I know on pictures of Christ
no I don't they don't the church
doesn't do angels have freedom of choice
yes God does not God is not served by
robots angels have freedom of choice but
listen to me
carefully when God seals you in right
doing is because you've decided that's
all you want are you with me so you
can't go back and sin when Jesus says he
that is unjust let him be unjust still
it is because that person has chosen and
demonstrated I want to live an unjust
life Jesus says fine go ahead he that is
righteous let him be righteous still
that person has decided I want to live a
righteous Life by the way you and I must
make that decision I want to live in a
sinless
world before the world comes now we show
God we want to live live in a sinless
world so when he comes and he takes us
sin will never come again because we
would have already decided we want to
have nothing to do with sin when Noah
went into the ark and God shut that door
Noah could not come
out are you with me those on the outside
could not get in those on the inside had
decided we want to be saved we believe a
flood is coming those on the outside had
DEC decided and God signed both
decisions we have Choice yes our
fundamental Choice we've chosen to live
in a sinless world the Angels who chose
the side of Christ they chose
righteousness now they're sealed they'll
always be righteous those who followed
Lucifer they chose sin they're sealed in
their choice they can never come back so
yes we have Choice choose Eternal
righteousness it's your choice
are infants saved when they die are
infants saved when they die I don't
know everyone born needs a savior
everybody needs a savior I do not know
what God will do but because God is so
gracious he does not punish the innocent
but then no one is
innocent because an innocent person
doesn't need Christ the only innocent
person who's ever lived is Christ are
you with me we talk about the innocent
man in the jungle there's no such thing
there are no innocent people only Christ
but God in his Mercy I believe will save
babies particularly if the parents were
right the baby may be covered by the
faith of the parents if the
baby circumstances were different God I
don't know what he'll do but I choose to
believe a merciful god will do
everything he can to save he does not
like to
destroy the youth leaving the
church blaming the
church go to John 15 blaming we're
always blaming the church for everything
the music is dead the sermons are this
the food is bad so I left the
church the peels are hard John 15 let's
read from verse one Father in Heaven as
we read teach us day God in Jesus name I
pray amen I am the True Vine and my
father is the husband man every branch
in me that beareth not fruit come on he
taketh
away it is the father that cleanses the
church are you with
me people leave the church because they
choose to leave the
church but sin has has given to us a
tremendous gift for blaming
others and so when Adam and Eve sinned
and God spoke to Adam what is this thou
Hast done he said the woman then the
woman said the
servant people choose to leave the
church and they can just as easily
choose to come
back no one can drive you out of the
church
they can drive you out of this building
they can't drive you out of the church
because they are the churches when the
Israelites ran from
Egypt did the Egyptian Army pursue them
yes or no God destroyed the entire
Egyptian Army meaning the Egyptians
could not bring them back they had to
choose to go
back the devil cannot order you to come
back to the world you have to choose to
come
out and so those whove left the church
may God bring them back they chose to
live young or
old they chose to
leave and may God so move upon their
hearts that they choose to come
back 10 minutes to six we have to stop
yeah this is the last question Pastor
Randy what kind of music is fit for the
church good
question good
question there is is a
growing belief in the church the
Adventist
Church is very common in the black
churches that the louder the
music the noisier you
are the more effectively you're
worshiping
God we associate noise with
worship the Bible says whether therefore
you eat or drink whatsoever you do do
all to the glory of God the question
always has to be is this for God's glory
not is this for my
culture is this now cultures vary don't
miss understand me but is this for but
we have the same God is this for God's
glory let me say something to you that's
complimentary this
sabbath I was listening to what was
going
on I felt as though I was in
church I had an experience different
from the world I wasn't in a stadium
with people making noise I was in a
church the music the behavior the
orderly service I was in
church that's how I felt if I were
walking down the street and I heard the
singing I would know immediately that is
a
church of course the cultural
difference the music that is fit for the
church is
music that is designed for God's glory
music that points the mind to God music
whose lyrics teach biblical doctrines
are you following me and music designed
and created for the glory of God not
secular music to which we put so-called
spiritual
words are you following me we take some
who are the popular singers United
States you take some Beyonce song and
you put some church words to it and you
call it church
music- that which is for the service of
God must be different by the way you can
go online and get 7th Day Adventist
philosophy of Music read it you know
music affects the cells of the body
certain beats can affect the cells of
the body really can the experts who talk
about that I'm not that go online look
for 7day Adventist philosophy of music
and read it Go on YouTube how does music
affect the body you'll be
surprised in Daniel
3 when Nebuchadnezzar called everyone to
to kneel before they
knelt music was played a certain kind of
music which dulled the
senses interfered with the ability to
make right decisions that kind of music
everybody
bowed if you go to a rap concert almost
all the time fights break
out no fight has ever broken out at a
classical
concert are you listening to me it has a
different effect on the
mind and the church should be a place
where the music takes us to God both the
tune and the words that's how I I felt
personally as I listened to your service
this morning keep the music of the world
out of the
church when the Israelites were
worshiping the golden calf Exodus 32
they were singing and carrying on and as
Joshua and Moses came down off the
mountain Joshua said there is a sound of
War that's how some Churches worship
particularly where I come from the sound
of war the onslaught on your senses is
tremendous Moses said no no no no no
that's not war they are
worshiping that's all I have to say on
that okay that's it yes let me thank you
for your easy
questions let me speak from my heart I
enjoyed my week with you I really really
did night after night you talk to me you
answered me I bothered you you took it
thank you very much I really enjoyed
myself thank you for being so kind may
God bless you put a double blessing on
your children I really mean that when
Christ comes make sure you've done
everything now so that your children
enter the kingdom ahead of you are you
with me live your life in such a way
that someone goes to heaven because of
you don't do anything that takes someone
to hell are you following me if you must
Sin Sin
alone if you want to do what's right
gather people with you whether therefore
you eat or drink or whatsoever you do
finish it for me do all to the glory of
God I thank the pastor for allowing me
to occupy his sacred desk I did all I
can not to disgrace him I thank Dr Jim
my brother and friend who was the human
instrument God used to arrange this
blessed experience in my life and I
thank you wherever you are if I come
across your mind all I want you to say
is Lord wherever that man is put your
words in his mouth God bless you I love
you if God arranges it well I'll be in
the Philippines in September
but I don't know where for a mission not
pass for a mission something in
September but I don't know where but uh
when I found out I let Dr Jim know he
can let God bless you I love you be
faithful unto
[Music]
death